“Have you confidence in me to trust me with
your watch until tomorrow?”
With these 13 words politely expressed, as
often as not William Thompson would acquire
another watch.
Of course, Thompson wasn’t even close to
the first to run such a daringly simple scheme,
but his bold method of gaining his mark’s
trust led a writer in the June 8, 1849 edition
of the New York Herald to pen a piece “Arrest
of the Confidence Man,” giving us the first
known documented instance of the term “confidence
man.”
Within a decade, Herman Melville published
his novel The Confidence-Man, which further
popularized the phrase.
Over time, this has been shortened to the
familiar “con man” or “conman” and
the derivative “con artist.”
Schemes like Thompson’s have been around
for seemingly as long as humans have had assets
to swindle, with various names for the scammers
popping up over the centuries.
As for early-on in the United States, before
Thompson, con men were commonly called diddlers,
after a character, Jeremy Diddler, from the
1803 play Raising the Wind, by James Kenney.
Analyzed in depth by none other than Edgar
Allan Poe in an 1840 essay, Diddling, Considered
as One of the Exact Sciences, Poe noted the
qualities necessary to succeed at diddling:
audacity, minuteness (focusing on the small
crime), self-interest, ingenuity, perseverance,
impertinence, nonchalance, originality, and
a grin.
Having his fair share of each of these, good
manners and being well dressed, Thompson was
remarkably successful with his scheme… that
is, until he was finally caught, as described
in the aforementioned 1849 edition of the
New York Herald:
Arrest of the Confidence Man—For the last
few months a man has been traveling about
the city, known as the “Confidence Man,”
that is, he would go up to a perfect stranger
in the street, and being a man of genteel
appearance, would easily command an interview.
Upon this interview he would say after some
little conversation, “have you confidence
in me to trust me with your watch until to-morrow;”
the stranger at this novel request, supposing
him to be some old acquaintance not at that
moment recollected, allows him to take the
watch, thus placing “confidence” in the
honesty of the stranger, who walks off laughing
and the other supposing it to be a joke allows
him so to do.
In this way many have been duped, and the
last that we recollect was a Mr. Thomas McDonald,
of No. 276 Madison street, who, on the 12th
of May last, was met by this “Confidence
Man” in William Street, who, in the manner
as above described, took from him a gold lever
watch valued at $110; and yesterday, singularly
enough, Mr. McDonald was passing along Liberty
street, when who should he meet but the “Confidence
Man” who had stolen his watch.
Officer Swayse, of the Third Ward, being near
at hand, took the accused into custody on
the charge made by Mr. McDonald.
The accused at first refused to go with the
officer; but after finding the officer determined
to take him, he walked along for a short distance,
when he showed desperate fight, and it was
not until the officer had tied his hands together
that he was able to convey him to the police
office.
On the prisoner being taken before Justice
McGrath, he was recognized as an old offender
by the name of Wm. Thompson, and is said to
be a graduate of the college at Sing Sing.
The magistrate committed him to prison for
a further hearing.
It will be well for all those persons who
have been defrauded by the “Confidence Man”
to call at the police court Tombs and take
a view
of him.